check out this split screen moment
president biden getting rolled by the
far left again while hanging out
overseas with the pope and european
leaders progressives refusing to budge
after his big announcement introducing a
new framework for his scaled back but
still massive spending agenda
we need
a little bit more than
an iou i feel a little bamboozled
because this was not this was not what i
thought was coming today we need to keep
the promise
that was made we've been very clear work
progressives have done our work
in getting everybody to a place where we
endorse the framework that the president
laid out today
all right jessica as the democrat at the
table do you feel bamboozled by what's
happening right now on capitol hill
for once republicans aren't getting
blamed for anything it's all just
democrats fighting with each other enjoy
the moment it won't last too long um no
i think
there's been a tremendous amount of
progress here we were two weeks ago
talking about how we were going to end
up at the 1.5 to 1.7 trillion dollar
range because that's what joe manchin
told joe biden he was open to now we're
there and ro khanna who's a congressman
from california uh the whip of the
progressive caucus uh was telling neil
cavuto ten days it'll be done both bills
uh there's a lot in there that
progressives should be happy about and i
think the attitude should be versus
nothing you're getting a whole lot of
something and everyone will get on board
nancy pelosi doesn't mess up it just it
doesn't happen she knows where people's
boundary lines are
and
she knew when she endorsed the framework
that it was going to work and biden knew
as well before he took off on this trip
that he was going to come back to a much
rosier picture so shannon it was either
a really good idea for the president to
make this announcement yesterday leave
and let them kind of hash it out or it
looks really bad because it doesn't look
like he's really involved as they
continue to talk about what may or may
not happen um and because greg has child
care issues that's why greg jr is
sitting with me now
um it is a huge gamble because you
either go out there and now you've
really put the pressure on your party
because you're leaving and you're saying
i expect this to be done by the time i
get back the first was by the time i
land i want one of these first votes but
like you said speaker pelosi doesn't
mess up in the sense that she's always
very aware of what her whip count is
what her vote count is and so she's not
putting something on the floor to watch
it burst into flames so we'll see how
she does the next few days but it puts
the spotlight on how much sway the squad
does or doesn't have they've lost a lot
of what they wanted in this bill and i
think they're finding maybe for the
first time it's a lot easier to go
campaign on social media and to do tick
tocks than it is to get hundreds of
members of congress to agree to anything
so
it may be a little bit of a reality
check for that wing so jesse there's a
game of chicken going on here because
progressives are basically holding
infrastructure hostage but senate
democrats are saying we already voted on
an infrastructure bill that was
bipartisan and we're not going to vote
for that unless you guys cut the
spending back so someone's got to figure
out to give here squad will blink
there's too much money on the line
they're getting a lot
already they got their climate army
hundreds of billions of dollars
for a little army little aocs paid
activists to
fight for the progressive wing of the
party that's big they also have
bureaucrat day care
elderly care government run everything
they're going to addict everybody to
government now everything is free you
got to take that win and rock with it
they also slipped in amnesty green cards
for silicon valley it is a lot plus they
jiggered with the bottom line numbers
they basically took 4 trillion and
cooked it down to under 2 trillion by
just fooling around with the sunset
clauses to fool the moderates
i'm not fooled by it everybody knows the
games they're playing here but biden is
an old man he's been in the senate
forever he knows how long he can wait to
get this thing under the wire they're
going to slip it in right under the wire
and they're going to get something
eventually
well greg now that we have little greg
yes i'm sure you're for all of the child
care spending we have in this building
you know the uh so you know the topic is
the far left threatens uh is threatening
to sink the biden agenda i think the
pope is not that powerful
uh-oh yeah
this pope this pope is far left let's
not forget that all right i refuse to
fall for this bifurcation this scam of
the squad versus joe because
that's only being done to make joe
appear more moderate right oh my god
look at the squad they're so far left
joe's old joe he's going to fight him
now this is exactly the same framing
they did with the spending bill here's
3.4 trillion oh my god oh my god maybe
1.8 doesn't look so bad so it's the same
it's it's the parallel right the squad
is the 3.4 and joe is the 1.8 suddenly
they both appear moderate and we're all
getting screwed i i didn't realize that
they're having the they still have the
army in there that's almost as much as
our military platform they have it
it's incredible the squad's been saying
that they're just trying to pass joe
biden's agenda and that people like joe
manchin are getting in the way so greg
is absolutely right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else